الآن دعنا نتحدث عن iPhone
عندما تم تصميم منزلق الجهير الذي تضيء المدينة به
iPhone 13 مع
مراعاة البيئة باستخدام العديد من المواد المعاد تدويرها ،
على سبيل المثال ، تستخدم خطوط الهوائي هذه
زجاجات مياه بلاستيكية
معاد تدويرها ، تتيح لك الكاميرا y الجديدة تمامًا
التقاط صور مذهلة في أي موقف
مثل هذه الصورة المليئة بالألوان والملمس ،
فإنها تجمع إضاءة أكثر بنسبة 47 في المائة
لتقليل الضوضاء ونتائج أكثر إشراقًا في الصور ومقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بك.
التركيز
المستخدم في جميع أفلامك المفضلة
يجلب بُعدًا جديدًا تمامًا
لسرد القصص
جيدًا ، فنحن نقدم هذه الإمكانية إلى
iphone
على iphone 13 mini سيختبر معظم المستخدمين
ساعة ونصف في
يومهم أكثر من iphone 12 mini
وعلى iphone 13  أكثر
من iPhone 12 بساعتين ونصف للحصول على عمر بطارية مذهل طوال اليوم ،
لا يزال iPhone 13 يبدأ بسعر
6.99 فقط.
t التقنيات المتقدمة
لمستخدمينا الذين يرغبون في الحصول على أفضل أداء لجهاز iPhone هو
الأفضل في فئته ،
تجربة الكاميرا
متانة كبيرة ، وشاشات أكبر
وتصميم لا
يصدق ، تدفع أجهزة iPhone هذه الحدود
لما هو ممكن في الهاتف الذكي
حتى مع كل هذه التكنولوجيا
المذهلة التي لا يزال iPhone 13 pro يبدأ  بسعر 9.99 ولا يزال
iPhone 13 pro max يبدأ من 10.99